and Ibraham, my favorite. Now, brother,
it's a it's a threebook series. You've
been with us since 2019, since we
started the show with your first book,
uh, Sword and Scimitar. Then you came
out with the classic, I think in 22,
Defenders of the West, of which I had a
small part in and the fact that I
helped, uh, Raymond decide the final
cover art and then you've come up with a
blockbuster about the Warrior Marks, Two
Swords of Christ. talk to us today
particularly I had you and Joe
backtoback because of these two
executive orders signed uh yesterday
you're you're an expert on the Muslim
Brotherhood and you've been a great
writer about the history of Christianity
and Islam and to be blunt about it your
histories third part being the two
swords of Christ is about the really the
warrior kind of uh interactions between
Christianity and Islam since the
founding of Islam is it not sir
>> yeah absolutely Steve that's exactly
what it's about I think uh The important
point of the two swords of Christ the
new book is that it literally looks at
the two swords of Christ the verse uh
where where the disciples after Christ
tells them sell your cloak and buy a
garment he who has no sword and they say
looks look Lord here are two swords and
he says that's enough. Now according to
modern-day Christian theologians that
verse means absolutely nothing because
it doesn't mean anything about swords
and so forth. But for the medieval
Christians and especially the crusaders,
it actually meant that there are two
swords to be used against two sorts of
evil. Spiritual evil, which modern day
Christians still acknowledge, but also
physical, secular, material, corporeal
evil, human evil, human agency. And so
that's how they understood it. And
that's why I think it's ironic and
people will be surprised when they look
at the read the book that it actually
this logic actually showed you how the
most pious men these men were monks
essentially okay were also the most
militant at the same time and there was
there was no contradiction between the
twain in their minds because they
understood that they what they were
doing was in defense of Christ
Christianom Christ's body literally the
the church and um they s they were
regularly martyed and they were seen as
martyrs So, I think it's going to be a
very different take for most how most
modern day Christians, including of the
doormat variety, as I've dubbed them,
who believe that, you know, their job is
just to be a doormat and be walked all
over because that's what Christ
apparently wants to see that no, you
actually had these extremely pious rel
Christian men who were also more
militant than any other uh character
from history. And as far as the Muslim
Brotherhood and what we're talking about
today, I think it's the continuity is
really remarkable when you see
>> Yeah.
H hang on. We're going to take a short
break. Raymond Abraham on the other
side. Abraham. One of the reasons I love
these books and they're so timely. They
talk about history, but they make
history present. Right now, we just
designate the Muslim or started to
designate. We didn't do it. The Muslim
Brotherhood a terrorist organization.
Texas has done it. We're in a fight now
as you know and have chronicled the
church. They believed in a church
militant. Why is a church militant and
two warrior monk orders from I don't
know a thousand years ago. Why are they
relevant today? And you need to read
this book if you want to understand the
situ situation we're in today. Sir,
>> Steve, without the church militants,
Christianity would have died out a long
time ago. And uh you know, I have a
quote I think in Defenders of the West
from Teddy Roosevelt, president, who
says exactly that. He he says he
basically says if the Europeans the
Christians of Europe had not fought back
he specifically names the Muslims and he
names all the long centuries
Christianity would have been snuffed
out. And that's what most modern day
Christians don't realize especially
those who sort of you know poo poo the
modern-day crusaders or the crusaders of
history and say they weren't real
Christians if it wasn't for all the
blood that they spilled on behalf of
Christianom. There would be no
Christianity to be honest with you.
That's very self-evident when you
realize that 3/4 of the Christian world
was conquered and swallowed up till this
very day by Islam. And I'm speaking of
course of the older, richer, more
profound uh region where Christendom was
located and that would be North Africa
and the Middle East. Um you know all
that was left was Rome in the west but
Constantinople, Alexandria, Jerusalem
and Antioch were all swallowed up by
Islam and it continued century after
century. And so that's what gave rise
you know these people weren't militants
by nature they really like they were
monks think about the hospitalers for
example their whole life was to be
hospice workers and serving pilgrims and
helping them and taking care of their
medical needs and feeding them and
giving them their beds. But at the same
time they also learned that the only way
to really help the pilgrims was to go on
the offense and preempt what was going
to happen which is an Islamic attack on
these pilgrims who were coming to
Europe. So they had no problem wetting
you know Christian theology with
militancy and and not just them actually
this goes all the way back remember to
Augustine um and so many other I quote a
lot extensively St. Bernard of Clvo
who's really the spiritual father of all
military orders and you know he g he
gives you all the verses and he shows
you the militancy behind it and it's not
just the Old Testament by the way as we
saw with the two swords of Christ in
Luke. Um, so I think uh if if modern day
Christians, like I said, I call them
doormats. And of course, Christianity is
teaches love and peace and forgiveness
and tolerance, but it's being pulled out
of context as if that's all there is to
it. What's great about Christianity,
Christianity is that is that it tempered
violence, but it still kept, you know,
the necessary forms of violence and
justice such as just war theory, which
all of course fused into what we know as
chivalry, and that's what made it really
great. But now we have this kind of mood
where, oh, you can't do anything. you
have to be a doormat and so forth.
>> Okay, I'm announcing we're going to do a
complete hour with Raymond to go through
his whole three-part arc of his story of
these three books and give special
attention to the military orders, The
Two Swords of Christ. Everybody go where
they go to order it right now, Raymond,
where they go to your site for your
writings and to order your books.
>> Thanks, Steve. Well, they can get it on
Amazon. Today's the release date,
actually. So they if they order it now
probably on Amazon they'll get it maybe
in in a day or two and from any other
online stores I imagine I doubt Barnes &
Noble is going to have it even though
it's a bestseller but um and also my
website raymond Ibrahim.com has links to
various books and you can also get
signed copies from there.
>> We're going to do an hour uh special
with Raymond next week. Raymond Ibraham,
thank you. Uh thank you so much brother.
Appreciate and love the book already.
It's just fantastic. Want everybody to
get it. Particularly if you got a young
man in your life, give it to him.